people need hope and they need to  believe in something and people out  there  are battered right now people come up to  me in tears when I do talks and we have  time together and they're in a room with  people who just want them to be all  right people are in tears because they  are exhausted by being surrounded by  endless madness here in America and I  find that really hard people want to  believe in democracy they want to  believe in freedoms they want to believe  in things like medicine and for the last  couple of years many people feel those  things are falling apart  um but my message isn't a negative one  it is a really optimistic one I love our  side I love uh Americans because you  have freedom hardwired into your souls  and you have a second amendment that I  that I applaud and uh you know it's part  of that message is to that we keep going  our fight will always be uphill